ihr erinnert euch vielleicht ich habe
einen tag lang für einen euro gekauft
und es hat wirklich funktioniert wir
mussten uns selbst nicht so genau ich
habe nichts runtergerechnet ich habe
genaue mengen von dem was ich brauchte
gekauft und es hat geklappt deshalb bin
ich froh dass wir heute für fünf euro
kochen das fünffache entsprechend mehr
muss eigentlich drin sein muss im rahmen
sein ich habe ein paar gedanken gemacht
was sie einkaufen können und ich würde
sagen einkaufen ist ein gutes stichwort
das machen wir nämlich jetzt also rein
in dem discounter und zuallererst einmal
einen becher tomaten geschnappt 500
gramm eine 59 absolut unschlagbar
vielseitig einsetzbar sank dann eine
süßkartoffel etwa 400 gramm damit euch
was besonderes spaghetti sechs
aufbackbrötchen dann speisequark und zu
guter letzt einen bei mozzarella und so
hatten wir da alles es wurde noch einmal
spannend an der kasse weil ein paar
sachen muss man ja wegen ist sie
vielleicht zu schwer die süßkartoffel 94
eur 80 stehen auf den kassen lägen aber
dass wir noch 20 cent übrig haben eine
sache ist es auch eingefallen fürs
frühstück wäre super 1 zwiebel zu haben
und wir gehen zum kiosk wo wir jetzt
eine gekauft haben und wenn wieder eine
einzige 20 cent über die anzahl
mit 20 center frühstück gepimpt jetzt
kann der tag kommt habe auch richtig
gemacht bis sie uns überlegt hatten als
wir einen kaufrausch logischerweise
nicht vergessen deshalb derzeit ein
leckeres frühstück und jetzt können wir
endlich anfangen zu kochen dafür
brauchen wir von allen sachen die wir
gekauft haben nur zwiebel tomaten und
die brötchen es sieht wieder relativ
spärlich aus aber ich sage nur echte csr
lecker ich mache nämlich bewusst kette
mit cherrytomaten mit zur vorgebackenen
backwaren also mit sowas kann man
wirklich gut aus budget gucken also
wahrscheinlich so wenig mit der back uns
jemand von einem kleinen bäcker bekommt
zu tun aber es ist trotzdem sehr sehr
lecker und 49 cent für sechs
weizenbrötchen ist unschlagbar wie immer
die größte ein bisschen an
ist eine schöne kruste auch beim
auspacken absolut fit und
schön backen acht bis zehn minuten dann
wollen wir ein paar knusprige brötchen
aus dem backofen die wir dann noch mal
extra anrösten werden weil wir nicht
frischem basilikum vom balkon 0 euro
weshalb das geile wir haben ja letztes
mal auch schon frische kräuter sofort
frei genutzt so ich finde das ist auch
immer noch fair wenn auch ohne hat auch
gesagt dass es okay ist
nehmen wir so eine gute handvoll mit
unseren cherrytomaten wichtig ist aber
bin ich zu viele gebrauchen denn heute
beim abendessen werden die noch mal
zitiert das cool wenn man komponente
wieder aufgreifen sollten zumindest
einem alter zwischen drei modi mich auch
schon wieder besetzen wir luxus köln
haben uns auch den luxus gegönnt nur in
einem laden einzukaufen und gar nicht
groß auf sonderangebot oder irgendwas zu
gehen daran merkt man auch dann doch
noch mal wieder das ist einfach das
fünffache von dem ist was wir letztes
mal also dafür dass du dich ihre ist ja
schon gesagt werden die fünf tage essen
auf den monat gerechnet ist 150 euro das
jetzt an einer so wenig klingt aber wir
haben ja die zusätzliche challenge
nichts zu kaufen also durch gefertigt
wenn irgendwas nicht aufbrauchen dann
ist das so dann haben wir es trotzdem
voll rein gerechnet wir wollen nicht
anteile rechner wieso haben italienische
gerichte eigentlich immer die farbe der
italien ein wenig olivenöl dran sei es
dadurch besser die tomaten ist ein
bisschen sind extra saftig heftiges
kabelloses frühstück das hält drei
brötchen
so auch bei dem normalen
sonntagsfrühstück so ist man selten drei
brötchen gehabt was mir bis hin zu
kleine fahne ausgewählten nur für
ausgewählte ich hatte ja ich möchte mich
da nicht in deinem kopf sachen
trifft bei seinem kurs jetzt auch noch
rangekommen trikot auch etwas aufs handy
wieder zu hause ist oder nicht es in
irgendeiner form bin der aber eigentlich
würde jedem einen vierten teil an iq
hier sollte klar wer draußen und sehr
sollte war jost ex zu hause haben wenn
man perfekt harmonieren und jetzt hast
du dir alles schöner und es ist
wunderbar vorbereitet ein glas frisch
gezapftes leitungswasser das bleibt
heute den ort bei wasser aber in den
nächsten stufen am stadien kann ich mir
dann auf jeden fall noch mal ein
bisschen mehr können wir machen jetzt
folgen ist wie gesagt schöner trend und
es muss auch einfach gut schmecken
gegeben jetzt ein bisschen von twitter
braucht weiß für was ich esse jetzt auch
so etappenweise dann ja nicht so
durchsetzen sondern ich mache halt aber
diesen hier passt euch schmecken
leute richtig kannst du so geschmackvoll
haben wir auch nicht bei mindjet hat
weil da mussten immer abstriche machen
das ist jetzt schon ein frühstück ohne
abstriche
richtig geil richtig vermitteln nicht
mal sonderlich linken urlaub ich habe
mir nicht länger jetzt erst mal
reinschauen spannend ob ich alle sechs
schafe mit sicherheit auch anzuprobieren
gucken wir mal ist mir danach geht
teller leer wie ich sehe was war so
lecker wirklich also ich hätte mir
schweren geiles frühstück heute
vorstellen können und dass im rahmen von
budget celik also schon sehr sehr knapp
zu mit
süßkartoffeln et la rucola beides vom
balkon ihrer echten laufen bei kunden
und klatscht weise krank und wir waschen
dies könnte auch ein bisschen bereitet
die gleichen berufe zu das ganz einfach
entwickeln die jetzt im vorjahr
herzlich für forum aber den opener grad
so dann schneiden wir unseren
schnittlauch einfach schön feiern kommt
wir dann mit unseren quark rein darf
sein livestream websites der live stream
in dem auch unser podcast entstanden ist
halle 2 wenn ihr das jetzt seht ist
schon die zweite folge draußen deshalb
schaut gerne mal rein werden nicht
umhinkommen die welt gequetscht über
fink liman über was man sich so
vorstellen business ideen oder wie sie
den dave bald in unterwäsche ist sehr
sehr hörenswert auf jeden fall für alle
interessierten was ich so abseits vom
kochen machen wenn wir uns keinen
knoblauch leisten konnten dürfen wir
knoblauch granulat verwenden
die perfekt geschnitten
[Musik]
dann schmecken wir das
jetzt minuten sind vorbei unsere
folienkartoffel ist eine folienkartoffel
noch immer nichts anderes passiert sehr
heißt selber mit der hand angefasst
hätte noch länger gebraucht ist jetzt
noch ein bisschen zu früh gewesen fällt
uns gerade auf ist aber nicht so schlimm
weil wir können ja wieder mit der folie
entwickeln nächste runde und ich würde
fast sagen man kann das ja sogar mit
schale essen ich begraben
das jetzt mit unserem
speisequark und ob eine ganze packung
qualität kräuterquark folien
süßkartoffel uns nicht richtig heiß
vor der die ist so süß die kartoffel
also wirklich so süß und ihr seht es die
schneidet sich die zerfällt in butter
schneidet sich mit der kocsis gedacht
hat noch mit ein bisschen balkon
frischen rucola natürlich das süße von
der kartoffel mit diesen würzigen quark
schnittmodell
google auch noch mal eine geile
komponente ich sag's euch ehrlich leute
ist absolut krass das ist so lecker ich
mache mir wirklich nie folienkartoffeln
oder ofenkartoffeln aber die ist ja fast
alle löst sich von selbst ab und die
schale ist wie kann dir wenn du so sehr
einfache gerichte dann lasst und auch
mit sehr vielen hunger diese ist dann
schmecken die einfach viel intensiver ob
du beschränkt sich so auf diese
einzelnen geschmäcker vielmehr das
stimmt ja also häufig neben leckeren
rezepte von rc einfach sind denn das
hier so puristisch aber alter schwede
dieser quark ist so lecker schokolade
ist als zehnter hat auch und das ist
auch wieder ich glaube wirklich mit fünf
euro und ein bisschen nachdenken schafft
man es ohne kompromisse unfassbar
leckeres essen zu genießen
auch zu machen lassen hier sind wir mit
den zutaten für das abendessen wir haben
tomaten nehmen wir ein bisschen
basilikum wir haben die brötchen von
heute morgen wie gesagt allerdings
ganzen tag über die reste von oven
genutzt ich habe die auf dem toaster
gelegt so dass die luft aus nahrung
bekommen sind jetzt richtig hart richtig
richtig hart und ich werde sie gleich
drei ich mache selbe größe
pato das heißt nichts anderes als das
selbe größe und klingt komisch bis auf
einen dinge in italien also ich hab es
nicht gefunden und dann wir spaghetti
davon werde ich logischerweise nicht 500
gramm nutzen mozzarella ich würde sagen
wir beginnen mit der tomatensauce etwas
öl hinein zu machen
fertig das wars es ist die einfachste
schnellste frische hausgemachte
tomatenpaste wie man sich vorstellen
kann die kochen jetzt einfach ein
verbinden sich mit zeit dagegen müssen
sei es dann und die werden einfach zu
einer richtig schönen frischen tomaten
sauce die habe ich ganz gerne gemacht in
unserem alten gewohnten müssen noch
keine küche da wenn dave mal wieder
wahllos tomaten bestellt hat man habe
ich so zehn reste auspacken von tomaten
genau auf diese beiden serien das sind
hier so leicht dazu markenfilm
[Musik]
hier geben wir jetzt unsere fahne hinein
bis sie ein bisschen farbe bekommen
haben man sieht jetzt schon kommt das
zieht so langsam hinterher also der
geruch ist wirklich das ganz besonderes
von muss man wirklich sagen
so wenn die brot kommt diese farbe
bekommen haben dann sind wir sehr froh
darüber
so das lassen wir einkaufen hier drüben
abschmecken wir gleich noch ein bisschen
abgeben bis zum basilikum hinzu aber
erst mal kommen wir schneiden wieder
basilikum ähnlich heute morgen den
streifen gegen den auch noch mal in
unserer stube das ist jetzt auch nicht
mehr so heiß dass der basilikum
automatisiert das ganze nur noch rund
jeder weiß ist am ende nur zu nehmen
will was aber auch würde fertig kochen
vermischen mit mozzarella bedecken hier
sitze ich vor dem bildschirm schon
abendessen eine frische pasta frische
pasta im rahmen im gesamtprodukt 5 euro
das finde ich schon mal da ist
eigentlich will man würde denken der
fifa dazu spaghetti fahrradtour also
semmelbrösel können du hast das
wichtigste verdecken vergessen sagt aus
zwei dicke portion gemacht hätte ich da
ich sagt irgendwie es seien weniger aber
erika nancy sie auch noch was von mit
essen selben preis denselben preis ich
habe immer noch nudeln übrig sowieso ich
gucke jetzt aber wie das ganze schmeckt
hier unsere kreationen an sich muss gut
schmecken das ist ja eigentlich genauso
schon mal so maria eingemachte da hatte
man mit einem partner zum beispiel hat
noch mehr drauf
diese frischen tomaten sind wirklich
einfach anders also für die kinder
sondern ist österreich und dadurch dass
es so viele dass du auch ruhig eine
säure in der passt aber überhaupt nicht
falsch ist nudeln sind auch am point
angegebenen zeit gekocht das ist gut
können wir mal eine richtig gute partie
sowieso besser als alles was du aus dem
glas bekommen es wohl mehr für die 2
wenn wir sind einmal format und das
überprüft und beim abendessen ein
gesetzlich komplett aufgebraucht und
auch wenn man alles nicht alles
nachmachen will und dieses frühstück
gibt es kekse jetzt diese passten sich
schon einmal tomaten macht einfach für
uns ist wirklich sehr sehr lecker würde
sagen man merkt auf jeden fall wie viel
einfacher es ist dass das ganze mit
einem euro zu machen kommt auch die
nächsten step doch bei zehn euro können
wir schon richtig krasse sachen zaubern
und danach wählt sowie suchen deshalb
fürs zuschauen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder man mutig sie
diese pasta und co